not since when president reagan was shot
in an assassination attempt nearly 40
years ago has there been this
level of concern over a president's
health the white house has not been
forthcoming on president trump's
condition
so we're going to turn out a 60 minutes
correspondent and cbs news senior
political analyst john dickerson he is
also the author
of the hardest job in the world the
american presidency john good morning so
good to see you
um does the white house believe the lack
of transparency here
is helping them
good morning jeff well it's uh not clear
exactly what the
what the white house believes i mean
they are being
mildly transparent so they are letting
information out and in this age where
everything is on videotape and where the
president is in constant communication
with everybody through twitter
we actually know more than in a lot of
previous presidential instances where
presidents really hid their medical
conditions
you think of eisenhower's heart attack
they lied to the press about that
kennedy was sick and lied about it both
as a candidate and a president
so uh this isn't the full uh
transparency on the president's
condition
but we we do know a fair amount and uh
and at the moment uh it looks like we're
being relatively kept up to date
although obviously there's uh issues
with transparency in this white house
that are broader than just the specifics
of this case
john what'd you think of the video that
was sent out of him immediately before
he left the white house
and went to walter reed
well it was striking in the sense again
you know this is a president who is in
constant communication through
his twitter account and um when he said
i think i'm doing very well
that tiny little hedge perceptible only
with a microscope but a tiny hedge from
the president i think i'm all right
is is striking for somebody who is
relentlessly
and overwhelmingly positive about all
instances even perhaps in cases where
not even perhaps often perhaps in cases
where it's not warranted
so it was a little sign of how this is
different than everything else we've
experienced in this presidency
john he said i think in the tweet as
well so um hedging
hedging in a couple different ways um
john when you look at the timeline of
events right now from last saturday in
the rose garden
through the debate to then what happened
the campaign events
on thursday what stands out to you the
most
well it what stands out is that as
evidence comes in that it might have
been this uh event at the white house
it's an extraordinary thing that this
many months into a pandemic
there is the possibility that there was
a spreader event
at the white house the most protected
building on
the in the united states arguably um
and it it raises it's not only just
extraordinary as a matter of history
but obviously it connects with the
central critique of the president which
is that he has not taken the pandemic
as seriously as a national matter and
now here
the pandemic comes home where it wasn't
taken seriously enough
at the white house we've seen plenty of
events like this the president has
constantly downplayed the need for masks
and now we're seeing the result that all
of his public health officials have
warned
people across the country that if you
don't remain vigilant this is the kind
of thing that can happen
john the white house says that the
president is still fully in control as
he's treated in the hospital here but
talk about when
or if uh the 25th amendment might be
invoked it certainly has been before
there's certainly plenty of protocols to
take care of allowing the president to
keep doing his job unlike ronald reagan
in 1981 which is a very fast moving
surprise event he was a very young
president at the time
this is slow slow rolling and a lot of
procedures are in place for the 25th
amendment
uh to kick in it would probably if we
get even get to that and we're a long
way away from that
it would probably occur in the way that
it has with george w bush
uh and even it was uh sort of
used with ronald reagan although he did
a kind of a fancy thing to get around it
but
um and that was this would essentially
be with the president's consent
hand over control to mike pence for a
period of time and then it would come
back to him
all right john it's been a while good to
see you thank you very much for your
time
good to see you jeff